[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez vu ces images
impressionnantes à New York il est tombé
en 24 he l'équivalent d'un mois de
précipitation despuis torrentiel sont
abatttu sur la ville paralysé je juste
montrer ces images impressionnantes
[Musique]
regarde
moi moi je suis je suis fasciné par les
gens qui veulent quand même faire leur
vie normale non mais sans déconner moi
j'appelle mon gars je dis écoute je vais
pas venir là aujourd'hui tu tu comprends
bien pourquoi tu vois bien le gars veut
prendre le métro
absolument non mais je te mais j'adore
non mais c'est vrai qu' il y a des gens
qui ont pas le choix non plus he parce
qu'il y a les SDF et cetera vous rendez
compte ça à New York c'est fou hein ils
ont déclaré l'état d'urgence et en fait
à New York ça descend tout de suite dans
les stations de métro et de train donc
ça s'est calmé là oui ça s'est calmé il
y a eu des gros dégâts il y a eu
d'énormes dégâts il y a eu plusieurs
stations de métro fermé il y a eu c'est
à Brooklyn et puis au nord-est de New
York ils ont dû sortir des tracteurs
parfois pour dégager des des rues là il
y a les rats qui vont monter ah bah New
York il a plein de rat donc donc les
rats ils vont faire quoi là faut qu'
massembrasse do Croll en dos
crollé ils font comment les rat il font
quoi les rat là quand il pleut comme ça
là ils sortent avec délectation ça nage
bien sû ça nage bah ça sort par les
toilettes alors bien sûr ça n je vous
l'ai dun jour il y a un copain à moi il
s'est réveillé la nuit et je vous jure
que c'est une vraie histoire il s'est
réveillé la nuit il a entendu des bruits
dans ses toilettes je vous le jure que
c'est vrai il a trouvé un rat les les
cheveux mouillés plaqué en arrière
commeass sur la cuvette comm mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai comme un rat
commeass était commass debout commass
les cheveux plaqués comass en beau gosse
il habit à Noï Noï sur scène
il a fait quoi du coup il a fait quoi
votre ami quand il dis avec il parce que
moi honnêtement moi je serais tétanisé
je sais pas je c'est vrai il a déménagé
mais c'est pour ça que moi je vous donne
petit conseil fermez toujours la lunette
des toilettes la cuvette exactement la
lunette voilà parce que la nuit même la
nuit quelle horreur après il peut
soulever avec la tête ouais il soulève
mais bon alors moi j'ai mis un truc il
soulève avec la tête j'ai mis un bail
j'ai un gars qui regarde juste
sur j'ai un gars il est commass toute la
nuit il est comm
non non r compte ou pas tu crois qu'il
peut soulever AC les toilett le rat qui
soulève les toilettes c'est pire moi je
déménage je quitte la France si je vois
un rat qui arrive comme ça la nuque
gainée
[Applaudissements]
stéroïde moi mais moi à chaque fois que
je vais aux toilettes c'est ma htise je
me dis imagine il y a un rat commeass ou
ça fait que tu regardes toujours en fait
quand tu lèves tu regardes toujours s'il
y a
pas moi je vais comme ça dans les pays
exotiques c'est les serpents qui sort
ouis mais un serpent ça me dérange pas
mais arrête ser serpent ça me dérange
moins qu' dans les ça fait mal SERP vous
imaginez êtes au toil AR t faire
ça et alors à la limite ça peut te faire
un petit je c'est pas franchement c'est
pas gênant gênant pas gant
gant ce weekend il y a énormément de
réaction suite à tout à l'heure dans un
instant on pour all à des punaises de
lit mais il y avait Pascal Pascal pro
sur d'ailleurs qui cartonne C news
record historique he pour C news pour la
chaîne C news euh qui a fait une sortie
qui a été reprise partout regardez et il
a fait une réponse ce matin regarde
est-ce qu'on sait pourquoi il y a plus
de Puna de lit aujourd'hui est-ce lié à
l'hygiène je vais poser toutes les
questions il y a beaucoup de
d'immigration en ce moment est-ce que
c'est des personnes qui euh n'ont pas
les mêmes conditions d'hygiène que euh
ceux qui sont sur le sol de France qui
apportent euh parce qu'ils sont dans la
rue parce que ils se peut-être nt-ils
pas accès à à tous les services comme
les les autres est-ce que c'est lié à
cela alors ce weekend sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a été un déferlement et il a
réagi à la polémique ce matin dans son
émission regardez pour avoir posé une
question j'ai été ce vendredi insulté
harcelé diffamé un journaliste doit-il
se justifier des questions qu'il pose je
sais que notre chaîne C news est une
cible et notamment l'heure des pro pour
les délateurs aés de l'espace médiatique
qui ont voulu voir dans mon
interrogation vendredi une connotation
raciste j'observe qu'à 7 heure aucune
plainte n'est déposée et pour cause il
n'y a pas matière il ne restera donc
rien de cette polémique sinon une chasse
à l'homme un déchaînement de violence et
un torrent de haine dirigé par des
minorités agissantes le succès de ces
news horipile mais rassurez-vous nous ne
changerons rien les chiens à bois la
caravane passe alors voilà c'était ce
matin il a répondu Gill alors quel que
soit ce qu'on pense de sa question moi
je prends sa défense parce que je le
connais et j'ai vu ce matin qu'il était
touché personnellement et la la manière
dont il a été une cible sur les réseaux
notalement harcelés et insupportable on
n pas le droit de faire ça on peut pas
s'en prendre à un homme comme ça après
après je vais vous dire aussi ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux c'est que il y a
des gens sur les réseaux qui voient y a
plein de gens aussi qui réagissent et
qui parce que ils ont vu un truc passer
et cetera et que ça ça a pu les blesser
ils ont ils ont mal compris et c'est
vrai que c'est souvent voilà deux trois
qui reprennent qui qui mettent des trucs
sur les réseaux et derrière c'est un
c'est un déferlement mais c'est vrai que
voilà après tout le mond tout le monde
tout le monde c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est voilà c'est jeté de dans sur le
truc à Mathilde Panau bien entendu hein
de la France insoumise voilà il y avait
qui il y avait bah il y avait tout le
monde ouais il y avait avait il a a
également beréranger Couillard euh la
ministre chargée de la lutte contre les
discriminations qui a pour sa part de
demandé à la Délégation
interministérielle à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la la haine
anti LGBT de saisir l'arcom donc
berérenger Couillard a tweeté face à ces
propos très choquant je demande à la
Licra de saisir l'arcom je n'accepterai
jamais les discours de haine dans les
médias comme ailleurs il ne faut rien
laisser passer oui sur le fond on peut
discuter bien sûr sur le fond mais très
franchement l'homme peut pas être comme
ça traîner dans la boue et derrière
l'homme derrière Pascal pro il faut pas
être dupe non plus le succès de C news
gêne beaucoup gêne certains C News a des
augmentations d'audience des hausses
d'audience considérables et derrière ça
c'est aussi monsieur Boloré qui gêne
donc voilà c'est toute une campagne qui
est menée qui moins me déplaitt voilà
justement moi j'ai moi j'ai juste un
truc pour vous sur l'empreinte carbone
parce que je fais une petite parenthèse
vous savez la Chine c'est 30 %
d'empreinte carbone ouais dans le monde
les États-Unis 20 % et la France
0,004 %. alors
donc êtes-vous absolument sûr du
0,004% oui c'est un ami qui M'ie ça
c'estuno Pomar on a voilà donc si tuux
pas tuux avir si tu veux pas avir les
gars du SPIP sur la gueule tu dis GG tu
voulais dire un truc oui bien sûr non au
raid numérique au harcèlement ça c'est
insupportable il l'a très bien dit ça
c'est petit 1 petit 2 effectivement si
Pascal pr ça avait été un journaliste de
France Inter je pense qu'il y aurait pas
eu de raid numérique tout tout le
weekend petit 2 après on a le droit de
poser toutes les questions quand on est
journaliste moi j'ai le droit aussi de
trouver que la question et la manière
dont Pascal Pro a posé la question et je
trouve moi un peu mal à droite et un peu
B cadre et un peu limite malgré tout je
trouve qu'elle est pas très habile moi
je me souviens vous avez reçu ici un
spécialiste des punaises de lit la
première question que vous lui avez posé
c'est Monsieur est-ce que c'est un
rapport avec la saleté il vous a dit non
pas du tout donc vous avez pas
essentialisé la chose vous avez pas
ramen parce en fait moi j'avais pensé à
moi à la base oui mais d'accord mais que
vous soyez autocentré peut-être mais
tout de suite vous avez pas dit en gros
oui mais c'est l'immigration oui mais
c'est les étrangers oui c'est les voilà
et là je trouve que tout de suite je
pense qu' il s'amuse un peu il cabotine
un peu il joue un peu de ça malgré tout
et voilà moi je trouve que bon voilà je
trouve que c'est un peu limite quand
même il y a un truc un peu je trouve mal
àrooit de sa part moi je pense qu'il a
le droit de poser les questions comme tu
l'as dit ça av été n'importe quel
journaliste lambda qui aurait posé cette
question personne ne l'aurait repris
d'ailleurs je pense pas que ça a choqué
les téléspectateurs je pense que le
processus tter processus sur twitteras
de tris mecs sur Twitter qui veulent se
faire pas
cas il font tourn et cetera et enfin
ceux qui lui reprochent ça et qui
l'accuse de racisme notamment libération
sont les premiers àir fait un article en
2018 en faisant un lien entre réfugié
rat et punaise de lit donc quand c'est
libération c'est pas choquant quand
c'est pas qu'Al pro ça devient du
racisme c'est honteux je sais pas si on
a fait un un un un sondage je sais pas
oui jacqu non je pense que on est quand
même redevable de sa question donc la la
question qui est posée de savoir si on
est responsable quand même d'une
question oui on l'est en journalisme
mais moi je trouve que ça a été une
polémique totalement disproportionnée
elle est disproportionnée parce que en
ce moment il y a un certain nombre de
gens qui s'amusent à s'en tenir à à à
trois mots qui sont réduits et déjà rien
que là la question telle qu'elle est
posée c'est pas du tout la même chose
que l'impression qu'on en a eu sur les
réseaux les réseaux sociaux ce weekend
donc déjà il y a une réduction là-dessus
et ensuite j'ai regardé la charte des
journalistes tout simplement lorsqu'une
question est mal posée que il y a une
imprécision la seule chose qui est
demander aux journalistes et c'est ce
qu'il a fait c'est de revenir dessus
pour réexpliquer ses propos donc il y a
pas pour les journalistes moi qui suis
pas journaliste donc non ce que je veux
dire non mais ça vaut pour tout le monde
ça vaut pour tout le monde Cyril ce que
je veux dire c'est que ça vaut pas une
saisie de l'arcom Mo j'avais dit la
dernière fois j'avais dit c truc et j'ai
eu sachez-le j'ai eu desoses plaines de
de de de de punaiss de lit que j'avais
demandé au monsieur comment on fait pour
leur [__] leur race et c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai eu de nombreux gens qui se
sont voilà des punaises des punaises qui
ont tweeté dont Jo la punaise voilà que
j'embrasse c'est vrai pass si on peut
juste dire que les réseaux sociaux ça
reste quand même une minorité et que la
plupart des gens qui n'ont pas les
réseaux les 70 millions de Français ou
je sais plus combien on est n'ont pas
les réseaux et sont pas du tout au
courant de des polémiques comme ça et
que ça reste une minorité de gens
insupport quand même alz on va parler de
Patrick Sébastien qui est actuellement
pleine promo de son livre il a alors
récemment fait une déclaration qui en a
surpris plus d'un il est revenu sur
l'air Mitou qui change le rapport entre
les hommes et les femmes parfois avec
des excès selon lui il a livré une
anecdote assez surprenante sur les
précautions qu'il prend désormais sous
les conseils de son avocat
regardez mon avocat m'a dit Patrick à
l'hôtel quand on t'apporte le petit
déjeuner filme et aujourd'hui quand on
m'apporte le petit déjeuner dans ma
chambre je filme pour prouver que je
n'ai fait aucun geste déplacé parce
qu'il me dit s'il a sort en criant tu as
perdu devrait voilà donc si vous allez
sur le téléphone de Patrick Sébastien il
y a des fougasses il y a des pains au
raisin voilà donc voilà donc Patrick non
mais est-ce que vous comprenez ça est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez changé votre
comportement moi je peux comprendre par
rapport à la réputation sulfureuse qu'il
a d'homme à femme et tout machin il a
une réputation d'aimer les femmes très
bien ben non il a une réputation d'aimer
les femmes c'est lui qui dit lui-même
qu'il aime les femmes donc peut-être
qu'il se dit j'ai pas envie de me faire
avoir comme peut-être l'histoire de
qu'il a eu avec DSK l'histoire qu' a eu
avec Neymar quand il a été à la chambre
d'hôtel avec la fille s'il filme pas
visage de la fille si quand la fille
rentre ou l'homme rentre pour pour le
petit s' filme pas s'il filme juste le
petit déjeuner si dans sa tête à lui dit
comme ça je suis sécure il a vu que
j'avais filmé le petit dééjeuner il est
rentré parti moi je peux comprendre
qu'il fasse ça ça peut être peut-être
une sorte de parano mais demain si on
disait bah Patrick Sébastien accusé par
une femme dans la chambre d'hôtel on
sera peut-être les premiers à dire ici
ah bah tu sais ouais Patrick Sébastien
il aime bien les
femes Mo ça me dérange pas qu' ça me
dérange pas qu'il me filme Mo ça dérange
pas qu'
seège ce qui dans ce qui est
sous-entendu c'est que les femmes
mentent c'est ça que ça sous-entend
c'est que quand tu une célébrité en gros
tu es à la mercie de de femmes menteuses
je rappelle quand même ici que 98 % des
femmes ne mentent pas alors il y en a 2%
qui
peutêéger pour les oui mais la
libération de la parole a entraîné une
judiciarisation des rapports hommes-femm
et maintenant pardon mais ça se fait
dans les grandes entreprises ça se fait
dans les grands groupes de médias
aujourd'hui dans les grands groupes par
exemple il y a pas une réunion qui se
fait sans que les portes soient ouvertes
avec les collaborateurs qui soient
témoins de ce rendez-vous chez les
footballurs par exemple et ben il y en a
qui font signer des décharges avant
d'avoir des rapports avec des des des
jeunes femmes pour dire en gros est-ce
que tu est-ce que tu es tu acceptes
telle pratique ou telle pratique pour
qu'après elle disent pas mais en fait tu
m'as fait ça et moi je voulais pas ou
alors on impose au filles de laisser les
téléphones à la dehors pour pas qu'il y
ait de trac voilà malgré tout pris ou
des vidéos prises à l'insu de du du
footballeur donc voilà mais moi je crois
que d'abord il faut croire les femmes ça
c'est le postulat de départ je suis
complètement d'accord mais il se trouve
que j'ai déjeuné il y a quelques jours
avec un ami que je connais bien et on
parlait de ça et il me dit écoute moi
maintenant dès que je rentre dans un
ascenseur et qu'il y a une femme je
déclenche mon appareil et je je filme
voilà franchement franchement je veux
dire c'est sorti dans mais oui c'est
triste mais c'est voilà c'est quelqu'un
qui a peur lui aussi qui a une fausse
accusation parce qu'il faut savoir que
dans un certain nombre d'entreprises
parfois on monte des dossiers contre des
gens et c'est très enfin c'est facile ça
arrive qu'on demande et qu'on fabrique
quelque chose aussi ça ne voilà ça ne
remet pas du tout en cause la vraie
parole de celles qui sont victimes mais
je peux comprendre cette attitude oui
moi je dis que d'abord un faut qu'il
change d'avocat ça c'est ça c'est clair
parce que Sébastien c'est pas un lapin
qui est né y a 15 jours il sait ce qu'il
faut faire pour se pour se tenir quand
il va dans un hôtel il sait qu' fa faire
témoign mais même famoignage de toute
façon il des pruv mais il faut des
preuves pourquoi pourquoi il cha FO non
mais il y a pas de preuve il sait très
bien que s'il y a un truc qui est dit et
que derrière avant avant que la lumière
soit faite vaut mieux qu'il filme et
puis au MO avocat si son avocat lui a
dit ou
raison bizar near il il a eu la même
histoire malgré que c'était filmé à
l'intérieur Ilou il a sorti directement
la
vidéo que j'allais dire avec Neymar
justement il a eu la chance d'avoir
l'idée de filmer le truc au moins il a
été tranquille tu as vu le nombre de
carrières qui ont été brisé pour des
suspicions qui ont été au final
démenties donc au final tout ces
personnes là tu les comprends dis il
faut que il faut que la nana elle filme
et que le mec il filme aussi parce que
c'est pas mec qui lui empêche de prendre
son portable et que lui il fait ce qu'il
ve après derrière c'est les deux qui
doivent filmer c'est un monde très
malheureux mais on est obligé le
problème c'est que ça va tellement vite
aujourd'hui un tweet une accusation si
jamais c'est faux vous êtes mort il faut
pouvoir rétorquer tout de suite avec la
vidéo donc c'est malheureux ça peut
passer pour quelqu'un de parano mais il
a raison de faire ça aujourd'hui parce
que s'il fait ça d'abord c'est ce qui se
comporte bien ça veut dire qu'il a rien
à se reprocher qui qui filme les
situations mais si jamais il y a
quelqu'un qui l'accuse à tort de toute
façon il est mort même s'il est innocent
et plus tard la se le seul moyen de
répondre c'est tout de suite avec une
preuve vidéo incest stable ilréfutable
il a raison allez